lines in the sea have been drawn
it's being described as a landmark
agreement between countries technically
in a state of War Lebanon and Israel
didn't engage directly in the process it
involved years of negotiations mediated
by the United States that's given both
countries guarantees if either
challenges the agreement a historic day
in the region of securing showing what's
possible under these circumstances to
achieve an agreement that
creates hope and Economic Opportunity
and stability for on both sides of the
Border there was no formal ceremony to
Mark the agreement behind closed doors
the delegation signed separate documents
which were then given to the United
Nations the deal is based on what is
known as line 23 gas from a prospective
field called Kana will go to Lebanon but
since a part of it lies outside the
demarcation line Israel will be given a
share of any profits
while the karish gas field will remain
within Israel's Waters and extraction
has already started
this allows Israel to increase its
potential to export gas to Europe where
there is a rising demand triggered by
Russia's invasion of Ukraine this has
provided a catalyst and a push and the
momentum for this agreement to happen
specifically because Europe is working
on reconfiguring its energy security
away from its dependence on Russian oil
and gas hydrocarbons and genitive energy
production in the Eastern Mediterranean
has been growing as Israel Egypt Jordan
and Cyprus have worked together you look
for proximity you look for accessibility
among many other things and so far the
East Med geographically positioned as it
is is proving to be that accessible
Corridor to Europe so they can start
getting gas getting gas out of Lebanon
will take time the deal enables
International companies to begin
exploration which could help Lebanon
with its crippling economic crisis
for Lebanon this is about the economy it
insists the deal does not signify any
form of normalization nor is it a peace
treaty for Israel it's about security
guarantees and in the words of the Prime
Minister yair lapid a political
achievement through which Lebanon de
facto recognizes Israel Hezbollah which
fought Wars with Israel rejected those
claims but since the start of the
negotiations the iranian-backed group
adopted what many call a pragmatic
approach it is the most powerful
political and military force in Lebanon
and the state would need its stamp of
approval
Hezbollah considers what happened in the
maritime border demarcation agreement a
great victory for Lebanon the people and
the resistance
the agreement may be limited to the
maritime border but the U.S
Administration sees it differently
President Joe Biden says it will harness
vital new energy resources for the world
nakura Southern Lebanon